House Majority Whip Steve Scalise facing
new threats to his life barely more than
a year after he was nearly assassinated
during that congressional softball team
practice
police have arrested 63 year old Carlos
Bayon of Grand Island New York charging
him with menacing the congressman after
leaving violent voicemail messages
authorities discovered hundreds of
rounds of ammo and firearm purchase
receipts in bayens home along with bomb
building information joining us
exclusively now with his reaction is
House Majority Whip Steve Scalise
congressman it's great to see you I'm so
relieved
this guy was found this was prevented
Lord knows what might have happened
we're also awaiting the election result
from Ohio 12 which we're going to talk
to you about congressman Scalise but
your reaction to yet another violent
threat against your life well Laura it's
great to be back with you and and
clearly these kind of disturbing things
there's no place for it in politics I
first want to thank once again our
United States Capitol police they were
very quick to act when my office
received this threat they sent the
information onto Capitol Police Capitol
police did research found out that that
this man has had a some real serious
concerns and it was hard to track him
down because he was trying to use
aliases but ultimately they found him
and he's in custody in federal federal
custody and hopefully he gets he gets a
serious sentence because you can't allow
this kind of threats and violence
against people based on their political
views congressman did he have postings
on social media about you did he have a
was it a purely political axe to grind
is he mentally deranged or a combination
of both well I guess we'll find out a
lot of that clearly he had some strong
disagreements with my political views
and others there were others they
threatened as well and and he's going to
have to account to that and the Justice
Department has him now but again my
thanks in and true appreciation goes out
to our law enforcement the United States
Capitol Police acting quickly and
working with New York authorities to
make sure that he got into cars
d-does does this what you see within
tifo across the country taken over this
Portland ice office black hoods the
beatdowns of conservatives intimidations
of conservatives in public you saw what
happened to charlie Kirk and his
colleague Candice Owens the other
morning in Philadelphia this stuff seems
to be ratcheted up the left blames
President Trump they say well he's
calling the news fake news and calling
them out and and and that's that's
making people more and more anxious no
you look at some of the liberal rhetoric
that's coming out from the left they're
encouraging and inciting in in many
cases violence and it's got to stop in
fact liberals need to call this out they
need to speak up just as we're speaking
up saying it there's no place for it on
the Republican or Democrat side I think
people on the Left need to be as vocal
at calling out this kind of violence
well we were talking earlier about
Facebook and Apple moving against more
conservative voices beyond Alex Jones
but other conservatives have seen their
voices diminished on these mega
platforms trillions of dollars of market
cap in these companies are you concerned
that groups like Ann Tifa which have
incited violence at these at these
rallies they have I mean they continue
on YouTube and so forth and Facebook
seemingly with impunity
other groups like them yeah it's clearly
a double standard we've pointed some of
this out in fact when when Mark
Zuckerberg testified before the Energy
and Commerce Committee that I sit on
just a few weeks ago I brought this up
the bias that we're seeing in facebook
as they put a new algorithm in place to
change the way that people get their
news feeds and where they're literally
we're starting to filter in a what from
what we've seen a left-leaning way in
and having a bias against conservatives
we've raised it to them and they've
gotten back to me to let me know that
this is something they're looking into
but we need to watch it closely because
if if they get into a position where it
looks like they're trying to become the
platform of the left there are other
social media sites people can go to
and we'll go to if it becomes a liberal
site they don't want their site to
become a liberal a monopoly we don't
want them to have monopolist power we're
almost out of time you predict this Ohio
12 is gonna go Republican Congressmen
yes or no I do in in the numbers that
were that are coming in or strong
President Trump going in Laura I think
really helped snakes race to the
Republican side it was not gonna neck
all the way Callisto